أحب الحديث عن الساعات التي يمكنني التحدث
عنها طوال اليوم ،
فلا يريد الجميع أن يسمع عنها
ولكن الجميع يريد أن يسمع عن
الساعات في قصر وستمنستر
سواء كانت ساعة بيغ بن سواء كانت
مهتمة فقط بمثل هذا المبنى المزدحم الذي
يعمل على الساعات.  يتغير الوقت
إذا كان شيئًا
أفتخر به كثيرًا في
إيان ويستوورث وأليكس جيفري هم جزء
من فريق صغير من صانعي الساعات في
قصر وستمنستر في لندن مرتين في
السنة عندما تنطلق الساعات للأمام أو
تتراجع في جميع أنحاء المملكة المتحدة.
تقع على عاتقنا مسؤولية تعديل
2000 ساعة قبل عودة المشرعين
إلى العمل ، وهناك ألفي ساعة في
مبنى البرلمان ، وهناك 500
ساعة تراثية هناك يومين
، ومهمتنا هي إجراء تغيير توقيت GMT
و بين عشية وضحاها قمنا بتغيير ساعة Big Ben
الرائعة في Westminster و  أعدنا
ذلك إلى الوراء ساعة فقط للتأكد من أن
كل شخص يمكنه الآن رؤية الأوجه يمكنه
بالفعل معرفة الوقت المناسب
تستيقظ صباح يوم الأحد
[موسيقى] ،
فهذه إحدى الساعات التراثية لدينا ، حيث
يوجد حوالي أربعمائة أو خمسمائة ساعة
منهم
، وهم سيعيدون
عقرب الدقائق إلى الوراء لإجراء تغيير الوقت
مع الحرص على عدم مضايقة الاتصال الهاتفي
و  إنه موجود في إحدى
غرف اللجان على طول ممر اللجنة حيث
تحدث الكثير من الاجتماعات المهمة ،
لدينا ساعات هنا تسبق تاريخ هذا
القصر وبعضها تم تصميمه
خصيصًا لهذا القصر ، لقد
صادفنا بالفعل ساعات
لم نعثر عليها من قبل.  لقد حدث ذلك فقط في
الأسبوع الآخر ، اتصل بنا عضو برلماني قائلاً إن
لدي ساعة في مكتبي لم يتم
تشغيلها منذ بعض
الوقت وأعتقد أنني كنت هنا منذ 18 عامًا
ولم أذهب إلى مكتبك أبدًا
قال إن هذا هو السبب على الأرجح في عدم
نجاحه ، حيث تم وضع تغييرات الوقت في
البداية كآلية آلية عملية
للاستفادة من
ساعات النهار في الصيف ، لذلك أعتقد أنه من المهم
الحفاظ على هذا التقليد في
المملكة المتحدة.
مفهوم التوقيت
الصيفي خلال الحرب العالمية الأولى قبل
أن يصبح رئيسًا للوزراء ، معتقدًا
أن البلاد يمكن أن توفر الطاقة عن طريق
إطالة ساعات ضوء الشمس المسائي التي
انتشرت هذه الممارسة في جميع أنحاء العالم
في الولايات المتحدة.
هاواي ومعظم ولاية أريزونا
لم يمرر مجلس الشيوخ في عام 2022
قانون الحماية من أشعة الشمس الذي
سيجعل التوقيت الصيفي
دائمًا في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة اعتبارًا من
الخامس من نوفمبر 2023 إذا مر
المنزل ، فلن تعود الساعات مرة أخرى
في المملكة المتحدة.  أظهر استطلاع عام 2019 أن
أغلبية صغيرة من البريطانيين يريدون الاستمرار في
تغيير الساعات في قصر
وستمنستر ، فإن صانعي الساعات المقيمين فيها
مسؤولون عن الحفاظ على هذا
التقليد حتى مع هذا العالم الرقمي
الذي تعرف أن كل شخص لديه جهاز كمبيوتر
مزود بساعة في الأسفل أو لديهم  حصلت
على ساعة رقمية ولكن MPS و
Lords أو الموظفين الذين لديهم بالفعل
ساعة موقوتة في مكتبهم
أول الأشياء التي ينظرون إليها هي
الساعة الموقوتة وليس تلك الموجودة على المعصم ،
مهمتنا هي التأكد من أن هذه الساعات تعمل كل يوم
لهم آخر ساعة من اليوم قبل القيام
بساعة رائعة الليلة ،
كما تعلمون ، هناك الكثير من
لقد تركت خطوتي في
العام الماضي وكانت 55000 خطوة ، إنها
تستغرق وقتًا طويلاً للغاية ، لكن الأمر مجزٍ للغاية ، كما
تعلمون ، يمكننا أن نقول لبعضنا البعض
إنها مهمة جيدة ، وعندما
يحضر الأشخاص للعمل يوم الاثنين
انهم في الوقت المناسب
[موسيقى]